in contemporary discussions about islam
a topic that often comes up is that of
salafism the salafi movement is
associated with things like
fundamentalism and even jihadism
sometimes but what is this movement all
about where does it come from what is
its relationship to mainstream islam and
what role does it play in the world both
in the islamic world and the world more
generally today
in this episode we're going to explore
these questions and the controversial
but very important topic of salafism
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
salafism is an important and significant
factor in the landscape of islam in the
contemporary world one cannot get a full
grasp of the wider islamic context today
without taking into account the salafis
who are often very influential in
certain regions especially in places
like saudi arabia the term salafism or
salafia is taken from the arabic phrase
as-salaf asaleh the pious predecessors a
term denoting the generation of muslims
who lived at the time of the prophet
muhammad as well as the following two
generations after these are considered
important as carriers of the most pure
form of islam because they lived close
to the time of the prophet himself or
sometimes contemporarily with him and
the salafis as their name suggests put a
major emphasis on this in very short
terms salafism is a religious movement
that seeks to purify islam and return to
practice it in a way that is in line
with the salaf the predecessor is
mentioned now important to remember here
is that this isn't unique to salafism
the salah for pious predecessors they
are a huge inspiration to most or even
all muslims around the world and so the
salafis aren't unique in putting an
emphasis on that per se and this is
pretty well expressed in a story so a
few years ago when i was doing my
master's thesis i studied the tijania
sufi brotherhood so this is a very
popular form of islam in west africa in
particular in senegal and the gambia and
i was spending time with this tijani
group and we were discussing islam in
various ways and in this discussion i
was talking and these different terms
came up like sufi and salafi and to this
group they at least most of them had
never heard these terms before they were
like what's a sufi and what's a salafi
they just saw themselves as being
muslims and that's it they practiced
islam in the way that they understood
islam to be practiced correctly even
though from an outsider's perspective
it's clear that what you know their
practice of islam was heavily sufi
oriented because they belonged to a sufi
brotherhood and so on but so then we
started to
me and one of their imams started to
explain these terms so this is what sufi
means and you know this is what salafi
means and so we explain the basics of
what salafi means that salafism
is the
you know wanting to purify islam from
innovation and returning it to the ways
the pure ways that islam was practiced
in the earliest days by the prophet
muhammad and his companions and the
earliest predecessors or the successors
and when we explained this
the tijanis there basically said well
well then we're salafis this indicates
something important all muslims
especially sunni muslims consider
themselves to follow the salaf asala and
to practice islam correctly according to
the way that they did
what is different about the salafis is
rather their methodology and approach to
finding out what's following the way of
the salaf actually means and often the
conclusions that they draw as a result
salafism is often called a modern
phenomenon even a modernist movement in
islam and this is true in a sense
salafism does come to prominence as a
movement primarily in the last two
centuries and often in response to
changes and circumstances particular to
our modern and even post-modern age but
this is also a bit too narrow of a
perspective if we define salafism just a
little more broadly as the particular
theological and legal approach to islam
that they are associated with then we
find salafism much earlier in history as
well we should of course take into
account the perspective of the salafis
themselves to them salafism has existed
since the very beginnings of islam
because this was the way that muhammad
and his companions practiced and
understood their religion to the salafis
this is islam in its truest and most
pure form as neutral observers of this
phenomenon and from an academic
perspective we can't of course make any
claims or statements about the validity
of such claims but i think the internal
salafi perspective is also very
important to keep in mind in these
discussions but putting this aside we
have tendencies that we could call
salafi in later islamic history too if
we define the term really broadly we
might be able to see traces of it in the
movement of the
hadith or the traditionalists which was
a heavily textual movement in early
islam perhaps most strongly associated
with the figure of ahmed ibn hanbal the
eponymous founder of the hanbali law
school their approach was one of
purifying islam of the rationalist
tendencies that dominated the religion
at the time by favoring a textual
approach where religion was to be based
only on the textual sources the quran
and the hadith and thus were important
for the increased prominence of hadith
literature now most people would not
identify the early tradition list as
salafis per se but their methodology
would have a major influence on the
movement in later periods the hanbali
school of law and theology is often
considered the most strict law school in
islam for various reasons indeed one of
the most foundational figures in
salafism and the emergence of their
characteristic doctrines was the 14th
century hanbali jurist and theologian
ibn taymiyah ibn taymiyah lived in the
immediate aftermath of the sacking of
baghdad and right in the middle of the
mongol invasions of the islamic world
and his ideas reflect this reality this
catastrophe was a punishment from god
according to bin tamiya because the
muslims had strayed from the pure
practice of real islam
his whole intellectual project was one
of purifying islam of various
innovations or bidah as he saw it and
returned it to its true form as such he
was heavily critical of the sufis who
basically dominated the islamic world at
the time and condemned many of their
beliefs and practices he also came to
reject and criticize some of the major
intellectual traditions that had
developed for centuries before he
rejected these speculative rationalistic
calam theologians and their approach to
god preferring instead an approach that
neglected all forms of speculation
regarding the word of god and scripture
for example if the quran states that god
has anthropomorphic qualities one should
accept what the text says without
speculating on what it actually means
furthermore he also rejected what's
known as taqlid or the imitation and
following of the established law schools
in terms of law and practice instead
preferring what is known as ishtihad
that the individual jurists should go
back to the textual sources and
interpret things himself only based on
that without necessarily consulting the
established traditions of jurisprudence
i have a full episode on ibn tamiya if
you want to dive into his ideas and
doctrines more deeply but needless to
say his ideas would become foundational
and central to the later development of
what we know as salafism today even
today ibn taymiyah is very important for
salvism and he is referred to constantly
as a source of doctrine and as a
defender of true islam from a salafi
perspective ibn tamiya and his immediate
followers while significant didn't exert
much of an influence during his lifetime
or for the following centuries and
remain mostly a minor movement until
relatively recently but its writings and
ideas were spread in certain circles
especially in the hanbali school and
would influence some significant
movements in later periods of these is
the movement that is often called
wahhabism named after its founder
muhammad ibn abdul wahab we should
remember that wahhabism is not a word
that they use to refer to themselves but
is usually a term used by others they
prefer the term al-mu'ahedun the
monotheists but there are so many groups
in islamic history who call themselves
by this name that it would get really
confusing so i'm going to use the term
wahhabism occasionally but keeping in
mind that this is an outsider's term and
that it can be perceived as even
offensive by some who belong to this
group that is often called by this name
but sure we should at least keep this in
mind as we talk about this topic ibn
abdulwahab was an 18th century reformer
from najd in modern saudi arabia
he sought to reform islam and islamic
society by purifying it of aspects that
he saw as heretical innovation much like
figures such as ibn taymiyyah he
believed that muslims had strayed from
their true religion and currently lived
in a time of jahiliyah ignorance just
like in the pre-islamic period the cure
for this was to return to pure
monotheism toheed and the quran and the
sunnah of the prophet muhammad
thus anything that he saw as
compromising this very strict view of
monotheism was strongly condemned things
like the intercession of saints or
visiting of their graves
as such he strongly condemned
significant traditions within islam at
the time such as sufism and shiism all
of whose ideas and practices he
considered to be reprehensible
innovations and even shirk which is
association or polytheism which is the
greatest sin in islam he even went so
far as to claim that anyone who followed
such practices were considered kuffar
unbelievers and apostates and it was
thus legitimate to wage war against them
this idea that one can excommunicate
certain people as unbelievers based on
their beliefs or practices known as
takfir has also become an influential
idea in salafism just like ibn taymiyah
ibn abdul wahab's movement was a
relatively minor one at first but it had
its influence of course especially since
he also allied himself with the
political figure of muhammad ibn saud an
alliance of wahhabi clerics which is
known as and the saud family that has
remained until this very day so-called
wahhabism did indeed come to have a much
more major influence later on and
especially with the formation of saudi
arabia with the saud family at its head
after which wahhabism became the
official doctrine of the state
so what is the relationship between this
and salafism often when we talk about
these topics salafism and so-called
wahhabism is often used interchangeably
as if they're the same thing but what is
the difference between them if there is
any it is indeed a little complicated
but we can look at it like this the
so-called wahhabi movement is a kind of
salafism especially when we define that
word broadly as the general tendencies
that have existed throughout history it
is one particular expression of salafism
as such but wahhabism also had a major
influence on the emergence and doctrines
of modern salafism salafism proper or
more narrowly defined as it exists today
and this will become clear later so in a
sense all wahabis are salafis but not
all salafis are wahhabis
in any case it is from around this time
that salafism starts to emerge as a
significant movement in islam especially
in the 19th and 20th centuries just as
it has always been it is a kind of
reform movement or movements that reject
much of the established islamic
tradition and many such movements
appeared in the 19th century
one of these that is often called salafi
is the modernist reforms of figures like
allah and muhammad abdu but their
quote-unquote salafism is very different
from that of abdul wahab or the later
salafis they have the same basic
approach in some ways criticizing much
of the tradition as innovation and an
appeal to hd had or reinterpretation
rather than imitation of earlier
president but the conclusions and
attitudes of these figures are very
different from salafism as we know it
they wanted to modernize islam and were
much more open to western influence and
education as harmonious with and even
beneficial to islam
they also were not anti-speculation or
against rationalism and religion in the
way that the classical salafis like ibn
taymiyyah were so while this reform
movement often known as the nagda is
often called salafi it is very different
in nature but you could say that this
tradition-critical approach to islam was
generally very popular at this time
partly as a response to colonialism of
course and this would appear in many
different guises
figures like abdul were important in
popularizing this approach but which had
many different results
it led to everything from islamic
modernism and liberalism to the modern
salafism that is the subject of this
video because aside from the nahta there
are many other movements that appeared
around this time that could be
characterized more strictly as salafi
so-called wahhabism is one of them but
there were also the ali hadith which
took form in the 1860s on the indian
subcontinents as well as many other
examples and it is from the late 19th
century and especially during the 20th
century that salafism as we know it
really starts to emerge
now that we have a historical background
and context and we have explored some of
the basic elements of salafi
ideology and doctrine
we can start to explore this a little
more deeply so what is salafism all
about
salafism is at its core a pietistic
movement based on theological principles
as we've mentioned they focus on the
idea of purifying islam and returning it
to what they see as the authentic
beliefs and practices of the salaf asale
the pious predecessors
the way to reach this pure state of the
religion according to the salafis is
through a heavily textual approach the
only sources allowed are the quran and
the sunnah of the prophet muhammad which
can be found only in the sunni hadith
collections as well as the consensus of
the prophet's companions the salaf in
other words and the particular salafi
reading of these sources are also
usually very strict and in a way kind of
literalist right so as we saw in the
beginning it's not the fact that they
follow the salaf that make the salafis
unique but rather their methodology to
how to reach knowledge of what the
practice and beliefs of the salaf
actually are and this methodology
involves particularly heavily textual
approach a very restrictive approach to
what counts as a legitimate source
and a very strict reading of those
sources as well
as opposed to what you could see
see mainstream islam or more traditional
islam
understood as islam as it had developed
over the centuries with its different
schools of law and its very complex
system of theology and so on
which also consider themselves to be
representing the beliefs and practices
of the salaf but had a different
approach they used the same sources but
they also accepted other techniques like
rational deduction uh like consensus of
the contemporary community like analogy
things like that and also generally a an
approach to the salaf that wasn't as
restrictive the
sunnah of the prophet and the salaf
includes a more broad perspective into
which certain
new
ideas and changes according to time can
take place within that more broader
perspective of what the salaf represents
but for the salafis rather it is a more
restrictive approach where it is only
exactly what it says in the sources
well of course i'm sure it's more
nuanced than that according to the
salafis in a very general sense you
could say that their approach is one of
a much more strict reading of the
sources this also means that they
emphasize a particular understanding of
tahit or god's oneness that puts them at
odds with other forms of islam including
the so-called mainstream forms
god's attributes are not to be
interpreted metaphorically but one
should accept the literal words of
scripture although without inquiring
about its actual meanings and not
falling into crude anthropomorphism
salafism is also characterized by a
strong sense of exclusivity and an
absolute claim to truth hence they
emphasize that everything that is
considered bidah or innovation in the
religion is to be actively fought and
can even resort to excommunicating or
performing taqfir on those who don't
conform to true religion and this
includes not practicing properly indeed
the salafis generally hold to a theology
where faith and outward action are
connected and the muslims actions are an
important factor in whether he or she
can be considered a true believer or not
this means that one can excommunicate
someone who does not follow the
religious rules like praying five times
a day or in the more politically active
branches of salafism that one can
criticize political rulers who don't
uphold islamic law and thus consider
them unbelievers on that basis
this exclusive access to true religion
leads the salafis to be very actively
critical of other forms of islam that it
considers illegitimate the sufis and the
shiis often face the bulk of this
criticism
salafis heavily criticized practices
like visiting graves of saints or
prophets celebrating the birthday of
prophet muhammad which is known as
mawlid or any form of intercession
between god and the believer
thus salafis will often call sufis
koburyun or grave worshipers and she is
as the rafidhi or rejectionists
this act of opposing of other groups
within islam is part of the process of
purifying islam of heresy and innovation
and its characteristic of salafi
absolutism bernard haikel says quote one
might conceive the effort that salafis
are engaged in to be one of continuous
boundary defense the the limitation of
the community of pure believers as
opposed to those outside it who are in
one way or more ways theologically
corrupted and in error it is probably
for this reason that salafis have also
developed and emphasized an idea known
as
which can be translated as loyalty and
disavowal a bit roughly in basic terms
this is an idea of association and
disassociation
salafis are encouraged to hold fast to
the true community of believers but to
actively distance themselves from
non-believers shun them and even
sometimes hate them it is a kind of very
strong us and them thinking but made
into doctrine mainstream sunni islam has
rejected this idea historically and
today but it has become an important
feature of many salafi groups
many have criticized it as a reason that
salafi migrants have a hard time
integrating into society or that it
leads to fundamentalism and extremism
but aside from these basic theological
ideas which characterize salafism and
which is
accepted pretty universally across that
whole movement or movements there are
also characteristics in terms of law and
practice the salafis are often quite
distinct even compared to other muslims
a salafi is immediately recognizable to
others through distinctive dress social
and religious habits prayer postures and
the content and form of his speech as we
saw earlier salafis often reject the
long tradition of islamic jurisprudence
and criticize the idea of taklid of
following the already established
president of established law schools
instead they emphasize hd had that the
individual should only rely on the
scriptures directly and interpret it for
themselves it is common in salafism to
claim that all the answers are clearly
visible to anyone in the original text
that the quran and sunnah provide
answers to all possible questions and
that an individual jurist or person can
simply advise the text and get the
answer without having to rely on earlier
scholars who have used various tools to
interpret it nonetheless in this these
salafis generally follow an interpretive
tendency of very strict and direct
reading but this emphasis on hdhad in
this way is not universal across all of
salafism for example these so called
wahhabis generally follow the hanbali
law school often considered the most
strict
and in this way the wahhabis and many
other modern salafis differ salafi
personalities like nasruddin and albani
criticized the wahhabis for doing
taqleed by following the hanbali school
and instead urged for the superiority of
age jihad but as we saw the salafi
movement in general is very influenced
by the hanbali school in particular and
many have even though they hold to the
idea of aged jihad or reading the
scriptures directly often followed a
line of interpretation closely aligned
with the hanbalis such as in the case
with ibn taymiyya in any case it is on
this basis that salafism operates and
through which it grew to great
prominence in the 20th century scholars
at places of learning in saudi arabia in
particular developed a strong basis
through which salafism has spread across
the islamic world and elsewhere figures
like the already mentioned al-albani
have been central figures in the
emergence of salafism in the last
century
but salafism is not homogeneous there
are many different groups and
expressions who fall under this category
who while following the basic doctrinal
model that we have outlined can differ
greatly in their approach this is
visible for example in their
relationship with politics contrary to
what many may believe the majority of
salafis are actually quietest they are
uninterested in politics and often
accept whatever the current leadership
happens to be
their focus is rather on the pious life
and the purification of the islamic
religion from the inside rather than
through political action nasa dean
al-albani is maybe the most famous
example of this quietest approach he
often taught that one should shun any
involvement in political or social
groups as this would create strife or
conflict within the muslim community but
there have been salafi groups who have
chosen a more active line probably
influenced by political organizations
such as the muslim brotherhood who are
not salafi some adherents have
considered political action to be
required in order to fight against
innovation and polytheism and have tried
to change political leadership that is
considered illegitimate actively that is
and of course there are those who have
taken this so far that their actions
include violence and this is where we
get into the topic of jihadi salafism
this tendency which is a minority even
within salafism claims that action must
be taken to change illegitimate
political leadership and that violence
is a legitimate way of doing this i
think no one has escaped the presence of
these kinds of groups in the last few
decades as they include groups like
al-qaeda and the so-called islamic state
these movements did grow out of salafism
and belong to that category more broadly
but they do not make up the majority of
salafis often when we talk about these
kinds of topics we see people completely
equating the two that all salafis are
jihadis and this is simply not true as
we saw the majority of salafis are
quietest they are uninterested in
politics and certainly
in that case they do not consider
violent
political action to be legitimate in
that way either but it is true as i said
that it comes from salafism and that it
uses some of the basic salafi doctrines
and ideas as the basis for their
ideology this jihadist strand of
salafism in the way that we know it
today appeared in the last few decades
many point to the influence of the
egyptian ideologue saeed kotob as a
central factor in the development of
jihadism he argued that it was the
individual duty of every muslim to wage
armed jihad against what he considered
to be the enemies of islam we can see
how salafism throughout the 20th century
grew to be a very visible part of the
islamic world today not only through the
very visible actions of jihadist groups
that we have mentioned but also more
generally through the basic ideas that
they have emphasized
even non-salafis have often adapted
ideas and terminology that is common in
that movement without realizing it
themselves the huge emphasis on opposing
biddah calling sufi's grave worshipers
certain interpretations of scripture and
many other characteristic features of
salafism that have sometimes crept into
non-salafi islam as well one reason for
their success other than the obvious
political circumstances such as being
given an official position in saudi
arabia is probably that the salahies
have been very good at producing
accessible information
salafis would often publish journals in
the 20th century and today they have a
very strong presence on the internet
indeed at least until recently salafism
almost dominated the islamic space
online many of the sites you visit where
legal opinions are given on islamic
topics are usually salafi in nature or
salafi influenced but are often simply
labeled as quote-unquote islamic and on
social media including on youtube there
is a major presence of sanafi
personalities who thus have major
authority as representing islam to a
wider audience now again this has
started to change a bit in the last few
years and there are more diverse voices
from the muslim community present online
in this way now
which evens out the actual demographics
a little bit but you can't deny that the
salafis have been particularly good at
producing accessible material online and
and otherwise um to to a wide audience
across the world so what is it that
makes salafism so attractive to many
people why has it become so successful
in the islamic world over the last two
centuries or so and what kind of person
is it that is attracted to this movement
well aside from the very obvious media
presence and and talent at producing
content in terms of media and so on
there are also other features which
probably attribute
contribute to the very strong spread and
popularity of salafism today
the claim to absolute or exclusive
access to truth and the quote-unquote
pure version of islam or of the only
correct way to reach paradise for
instance is indeed appealing to many as
mayor heikel and adrawi points out a lot
of its success lies precisely in this
ability to quote morally upstage the
opponent and in quotes its capacity to
say we are better than you salafism also
offers a sense of universalism that
purity of its doctrine transcending
national cultural borders and speaking
directly to the individual and inviting
them to a community beyond all of these
aspects indeed salafism has proved
especially popular and successful among
young muslims migrants who feel
discriminated against or who feel
confused about their various identities
and the downtrodden in general
quotes
in a contentious age salafism transforms
the humiliated the downtrodden
disgruntled young people the
discriminated migrant or the politically
repressed into a chosen sect at first
najib that immediately gains privileged
access to the truth salafis are
therefore able to contest the hegemonic
power of their opponents parents the
elite the state or dominant cultural and
economic values of the global capitalist
system as well as the total
identification with an alien nation
which nation-states and europe impose
because of its emphasis on doctrinal
purity and not politics salafism more
than the muslim brotherhood or hispah
tahrir has been able to empower
individuals by providing a universal
alternative model of truth and social
action
perhaps we can then understand at least
part of the reason why salafism has
become such a significant part of the
wider islamic world today as we have
seen in the most general sense the basic
doctrinal ideas the the features of
salafism dates back very far in history
according to salafis even back to the
time of the prophet muhammad himself but
at the same time the particular ways
that it has manifested itself today in
salafism as we know it is also in direct
response to circumstances in the
contemporary modern world it is a
controversial topic even among muslims
themselves around the world according to
themselves salafism is of course the
most pure form of islam the only pure
form of islam and the true way of
practicing and understanding that
religion whereas for their critics or
their enemies it's considered an
innovation as always as neutral
observers it is not our place to make
any statements about the validity of any
of these claims on either side of the
debate but now we have a better
understanding both historically the
historical context and the basic outline
of the features of salafism so that we
can better understand what it is what
role it plays in the islamic world
how
salafis themselves understand their
religion how they understand the
religion of islam and the way that
salafism
very much helps shape and form the wider
islamic world today you can of course
look forward to more content about
topics relating to the islamic world
generally it's kind of one of the main
things we do here let's talk religion
for now i hope this was an interesting
and informative video about the very
important salafi movements of modern
islam and that it clarified a few things
and gave you a broader perspective on
this subject i would like to thank my
patrons as always who support this
channel and my work
enabling me to provide you with free
content free educational content about
religion and all its various features
both historically and today so thank you
all so so much i appreciate it
so much i can't express how much that
means to me everyone feel free to leave
a comment like the video and continue
this discussion in the comment section
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign